Look,
during the last few days he.
H.
Bildu has attempted with the apple of independence
to PNV
and for the moment I am neither the PNV nor its candidate.
I have heard them say that they are not going to join e.
H.
Bildu to achieve this goal.
What's more,
some of them today were and were acting as pro-independence supporters
and to bet on the right to decide,
for the right to self-determination that he went to defend
last week to Brussels the endakari Urcuyo.
Well,
that's the risk.
That is the risk.
Because they are not telling us
that they will not come together to achieve this goal.
On the contrary,
they do not answer because they know they are looking forward to
to achieve that goal and that at some point
are going to unite to fight for him.
Well,
Euskadi doesn't need adventures.
Euskadi does not need risks
and if someone wants that not to happen,
you already know what to do in the next elections
the socialist party,
which is the only guarantee
that no one gets us into any mess
and we are working
in what actually
matters to the citizenry,
which is in solving
their problems